in 2009 the pinnacle of the franchise
pokemon gold and silver were remade for
the Nintendo DS and with the remakes
came some added content that they
decided to throw in one of which ended
up being strangely disturbing the event
is triggered if you visit the ruins of
alph with a special event Pokemon who
can only be acquired in a one-time
in-store giveaway a researcher bumps
into you and brings you down into the
ruins where he says something feels
different and the you know and
hieroglyphics on the wall seem to be
staring at him if you aren't familiar
you known are these mysterious Pokemon
that represent letters of the alphabet
this is where things get weird you
suddenly hear a high-pitched laughter
and the screen fades to black you'll
next find yourself in a dark temple
supposedly far off from anywhere you've
been before
after some exposition you're brought
back to the temple and asked to choose
one of the ancient circles on the ground
upon choosing your Pokemon will float to
the center of the room and a horde of
uknown will swirl around you as you're
engulfed in a huge light this animation
is graphically not like anything else
we've seen in these games giving you
this is a realistic vibe but it gets
weirder from their creepy Gregorian
music starts playing and were taken
through a slideshow of the creation of
the universe using real-life photographs
I've always found the use of mixed
mediums to be creepy and this is no
exception
seeing man-made cities from our world
just comes as a shock after looking at
an entire games worth of this one
specific art style the event ends with
you being given this egg containing a
new pokémon before reappearing in the
ruins and the researcher explains that
you just disappeared and reappeared
before his eyes the mystery deepens
while we're still on the ruins of alph
they are pretty creepy even under the
game's normal circumstances once you get
near the ruins you can start to pick up
a strange signal on your radio
[Music]
it's so broken and distorted it sounds
more like part of some Pokemon
creepypasta than an actual part of the
game the player is tasked with
completing these ancient block puzzles
each depicting an ancient prehistoric
Pokemon the completion of these puzzles
opens up a trapdoor leading to the
underground tombs where you know and
will start to randomly appear the
question is who could have built this
place all those millions of years ago
and for what purpose even after
completing everything the mystery of the
runes is never fully solved another
creepy location in the series is ends
room in Pokemon black and white and was
an orphan adopted by the evil Team
Plasma and one of the more interesting
characters in the series he poses the
idea of liberating Pokemon from their
trainers as an animal-rights type of
thing but it turns out that his
superiors were just lying and trying to
separate other Pokemon trainers from
their Pokemon so that they would have
all of the power in the world seeing
ends childhood room shows how
manipulated he was they spent tons of
money to keep him occupied but
everything in the room is there to keep
him entertained by himself without the
need for any friends he has a train set
a basketball hoop dartboard even his own
halfpipe you can go back to the room in
the sequels which take place two years
after Team Plasma betrays n now the room
seems to have been destroyed most likely
by n in a rage after discovering his
faux father's true intentions and how he
was used the music box in the room also
seems to have been broken as the
soundtrack sounds much more sinister
[Music]
perhaps the creepiest part about ends
rim now can be seen if you examine the
half pipe the character observes that
it's been damaged by the scratches of
Pokemon did ends father give him
potentially harmful Pokemon as part of
his plan to turn n against the Union
shared by Pokemon and their trainers we
never fully find out but it looks grim
based on the evidence presented in the
game while we're on the topic of harmful
Pokemon there are many that look
innocent but actually have extremely
dark descriptions others are just
downright terrifying cough egregious it
has been said that they swallow those
who get too close and turned them into
mummies they like to eat gold nuggets
they pretend to be elaborate coffins to
teach grave robbers their bodies are
covered in pure gold
so this Pokemon cough egregious
literally has been known to swallow
adults whole it makes you think twice as
the fourteen-year-old protagonists of
these games whenever you encounter one
while exploring who knew that your
adventure could come to a close at any
moments literally let's look at another
Gengar to steal the life of its target
it slips into the preys shadow and
silently waits for an opportunity it's
pretty unnerving to consider that
something could be watching you from
your own shadow especially if you're the
Pokemon clefable many have theorized
that Gengar is actually the dark version
or at least the shadow of clefable
haunting it wherever it goes
given their identical shape it's
possible that the name Gengar is short
for doppelganger because Gengar is a
ghostly double of clefable if such a
thing exists it's chilling to think
about what else is out there do humans
have a shadow entity following them as
well
moving on sandy ghast is a ghost slash
ground-type pokémon resembling a sand
castle from Pokemon Sun and Moon its
evolution is called hallasan and they
can be found on the sunny shores of hano
beach sandy gasps entry reads as follows
it takes control of anyone who puts a
hand in its mouth and so it adds to the
accumulation of its sand bound body
that's creepy enough on its own but
let's look at the description of the
evolved form Palace and buried beneath
the castle are masses of dried up bones
from those whose vitality it has drained
these tropical beaches don't seem quite
so bright and cheerful after learning
that it gets worse when you consider the
context hanno beach is a public beach
right next to two huge resorts the place
is covered with unsuspecting tourists
and young children can be found playing
at the resort and don't fall asleep on
that beach chair because your kid could
end up as a pile of bones beneath these
sunny shores if you aren't careful not
all the creepy Pokemon are ghost types
however Beedrill Beedrill is extremely
territorial no one should ever approach
its nest this is for their own safety
if angered they will attack in a furious
swarm that may not sound that scary but
let's not forget that Beedrill are three
foot tall 65 pound poisonous bugs with
giant stingers for hands
I think the wasps in our world are
already scary enough as it is I do not
need a swarm of child-sized Beedrill
coming after me with their glowing red
eyes the thought of that is enough to
make me never want to go outside again
with that being said let's take a break
from the creepy pokedex entries I think
we could all use one and go inside some
of the creepy buildings that the world
of Pokemon has to offer
take cinnabar mansion for example it's
the burndown well they call it burn down
but I guess it's just burned mansion of
a researcher who has been studying the
legendary Pokemon mu and attempting to
replicate its DNA his journal entries
can be found in the mansion that is if
you make it past the mad scientists and
burglars who have come to scavenge the
remains the journals tell of
approximately a two year period where
researchers found and captured new
cloned it and gave
earth 2 mu 2 mu 2 became far too
powerful for them to handle destroyed
the mansion and fled into the wild
eventually settling in at cerulean
cavern mu 2 is the strongest Pokemon in
the game so much so that only the
Pokemon League champion is permitted
entering into the cavern as for the
researcher I think it's pretty obvious
what happened to him in our real world
with emerging technologies such as
cloning and AI it's scary to think about
these things growing more potent than
mankind and what type of damage could
possibly incur the most universally
recognized creepy location in the
Pokemon world of course is lavender town
with its creepy headache-inducing music
frequencies ghost hands resting on your
shoulder and no these aren't all
ghost-type pokémon some of them are the
real ghosts of deceased Pokemon the rest
of the horror community here on YouTube
has done a fine job of covering lavender
town so I'm not gonna spend too much
time on it but it does tie into the next
topic death of Pokemon one theory says
after you defeat blue on the SS n since
he didn't have access to a Pokemon
Center he was unable to heal his radical
injuries properly in time the next time
you see blue in the pokemon tower the
final resting place of Pokemon he makes
a comment wondering why your character
is at the pokemon tower
seeing as how none of your Pokemon look
dead when you proceed to battle him the
radical is missing from his party I
guess you could say that you eradicated
the competition okay that's horrible
another haunted house location can be
found in the fourth generation of games
where you can find an abandoned house
deep in the aterna forest known as the
old chateau many of the characters you
meet in that area of the game express
fear and anxiety about the old chateau
even the gym leader supposedly the
strongest trainer in that nearby city
refused to go any further than the front
gates inside you'll find an array of
ghost-type pokémon and while there don't
seem to be any actual ghost of dead
Pokemon here what you'll find may
actually be more disturbing from time to
time you can spot the ghosts of the
little girl who once lived there and her
Butler floating around the manor
the girl can be seen in the next room
over if you go in someone in the
bedrooms and the butler can be seen
occasionally on the far side of the
dining room it's not possible to reach
and talk to either of them but they lack
the same walking animations that all of
the other characters have in these games
and instead just float across the screen
there's also a book you can find in
library all of the pages are blank other
than this one something so peculiar
should make off with the mother we don't
know much about the family who lived in
the old Chateau but it seems like after
some dark Spirit made off with the
mother something happened to the
daughter and the butler causing the
father to flee the mansion and never
return we see another human ghost
character in pokemon black and whites
when traveling across an area known as
the marvelous bridge you may
occasionally encounter a young girl
staring off the side of the bridge if
you approach this girl she will simply
disappear frightening the man standing
to her right upon further investigation
an old woman will reveal that a young
girl with an abra used to play around in
the area before the bridge had been
built we don't learn anything else until
the sequel's taking place two years
later the player will stumble upon a
location simply referred to as strange
house on the opposite side of the
mountain that Marvel Bridge is located
on inside the house you'll find
levitating objects and random furniture
thrown about most of the rooms in the
library there are several books
pertaining to the link between Pokemon
and nightmares in reading each of these
books they explain about Cresselia the
anti nightmare Pokemon
Darkrai the nightmare pokemon drowsy the
dream eating Pokemon hypno the sleep
inducing Pokemon and some of the moves
that these Pokemon may use to haunt the
nightmares of Pokemon or people
exploring the house will lead you to
meet the ghost girl when she just
appears in front of you only this time
she'll speak to you
[Music]
you can encounter her again in a
different part of the house where she
now has new dialogue
[Music]
finally if you go into the bedroom she
appears one more time
[Music]
with that she gives you the lunar wing
and disappears you can use it to summon
Cresselia it could be speculated that
the girl was trying to summon Cresselia
herself because some of her dreams were
haunted by the evil Darkrai possibly
driving her to the breaking point and
death that would explain why she had so
many books about Pokemon dreams and
nightmares there's another ghost later
on that I'd like to discuss but first
let's look at some more disturbing
pokedex entries I'll start with the
after mentioned drowsy drowsy it
remembers every dream it eats it rarely
eats the dreams of adults because
childrens are much tastier if your nose
becomes itchy while you are sleeping
it's a sure sign that drowsy is standing
above your pillow and trying to eat your
dream through your nostrils the idea of
waking up to see this horrifying thing
attempting to suck your dream out
through your nose is terrifying
not to mention that Dream Eater is one
of the most devastating psychic type
moves in the game powerful enough at
times to bring down a behemoth Snorlax
getting your dream eaten sounds like one
of the most painful and scarring
experiences imaginable but the horror
does not end there
drowsy evolves into hypno hypno it
carries a pendulum like device there was
once an incident in which it took away a
child it hypnotized so not only do these
things look like a creepy old predator
but they're actually known to come into
children's bedrooms at night hypnotized
them and lead them back out into the
wild into their nest where several
Hypno's and drowsies feast upon the
children's dreams imagine waking up as a
child and being in a dark cave not
knowing where you are or how you got
there and being surrounded by an entire
horde of these nightmare inducing
creatures who want to kidnap you and
devour the thoughts that occupy your
head during a dream the next one is a
personal favorite from the seventh
generation of games mimic you a lonely
Pokemon it conceals its terrifying
appearance beneath an old rag so it can
get closer to people and other Pokemon
its actual appearance is unknown a
scholar who saw what was under its rag
overwhelmed by terror and died from the
shock so if this is a Pokemon that
nobody has actually seen the true form
of except for that one guy apparently
mimic you disguises itself as a Pikachu
because it's seen that Pikachu is the
most popular Pokemon among humans and it
wants to be loved by its human trainers
ah how adorable
until you remember the fact that
underneath that cloth what lies beneath
the disguise the true form of mimic you
is something so disturbing so obscene so
terrifying that the very sight of it
will literally scare the trainer to
death but at least the disguise is cute
right know in Pokemon there's an
alternate color palette for each species
which are extremely rare called shinies
look at the shiny form of mimic you
that's not shiny at all it looks like it
belongs in the Zack Snyder movie
wouldn't want to run into one of those
in a dark alley oh yeah that's the other
creepy thing about mimic you you can
only find it in one place
an abandoned convenience store at the
end of a broken forgotten Road when you
first meet mimic you you go into a
secret backroom where your camera turns
on all on its own you can then examine
the cold dark little room and discover
that's plastered with all these joyful
pictures and magazine clippings of
Pikachu so it seems like mimic U is
either obsessed with Pikachu or
absolutely hates them which is creepy
either way you look at it then somehow
mimic you just appears behind you and
initiates a battle I'm just glad to be
the player character in that situation
and not Pikachu imagine you are Pikachu
you go into this room and find all of
these photos of yourself plastered
around ones you don't even remember
being taken then you turn around and
someone in a costume resembling you is
standing there blocking the only exit
while Pikachu in mimic you do share some
similarities another interesting pair
are cubone and shedinja cubone it always
wears the skull of its dead mother so no
one has any idea what its hidden face
looks like shedinja a discarded bug
shell that came to life peering into the
crack on its back is said to steal one
spirit
both of these pokemon hide inside the
skeleton of another pokemon in their
evolutionary line refused to show their
faces and undoubtedly have some personal
issues
here's another Pokemon that looks like
it would make a great pet but upon
further investigation you may want to
stay miles and miles from it
Esper the organ that emits its intense
psychic power is sheltered by its ears
to keep power from leaking out it has
enough psychic energy to blast
everything within 300 feet of itself but
no control over its power the eyes on
this Pokemon are already a little
unnerving and the teeth don't really
help but if you try to play with this
pokemons ears the look that it gives you
will be burned into your memory in the
worst way possible the sound you just
heard it comes from the this Pokemon
drift Lyn drifloon stories go then it
grabbed the hands of small children and
drags them away to the afterlife it
dislikes heavy children
this Pokemon might look like a balloon
you would pay too much money for it
affair but it's actually a ghost type
Pokemon and like many of the creepy
Pokemon on this list it abducts children
what is it with Game Freak and child
abduction anyway I think we've all had
the childhood moment of letting go of a
beloved balloon maybe we should just be
glad that the balloon lets go of us
before I get to what I see as the
creepiest thing to have happened in the
Pokemon franchise let me tell you about
something that may have not been
intentionally creepy but I found rather
off-putting anyways there is an area
called Mountain moon which you go
through many times in the first two
generations of games what I never
realized for the longest time was that
going through Mountain Moon Square on a
Monday night in pokemon gold and silver
resulted in a special event so when I
accidentally stumbled upon this and
heard this strange music in a location
that I had rolled through many
with no music change I was a bit shook
I'll just roll the clip the noises that
they make are so disturbing it's like
there's just some kind of dark undertone
then there's the way that the rock just
appears that which is almost like a
jump-scare I guess the story goes that
the Clefairy come from outer space and
the rock is a meteor that they summoned
with their dance I had played this game
for so long before discovering that
little scene that it just seems so
unreal to me when it finally happened
alright it looks like we've reached the
number one scariest thing in all of
Pokemon I'll just set it up for you a
little bit in Pokemon X&Y
there's a lot to explore in the biggest
city lumiose city it's probably in the
best part of the game you can
rollerblade around the music is great
and there's plenty to explore then this
happens
[Music]
you
you
yep then she just disappears it's never
explained you never see her again nobody
on the internet has any idea who this
girl is or why this happens I was kind
of tired and dozing off when it happened
to me so I think that it shocked me even
more I kind of thought that I had dozed
off and had a weird dream the music
stops the way she just slides across the
screen is very unsettling I actually had
to look it up online to make sure it was
real after all maybe I had one of those
fabled Haunted cartridges honestly the
only reason I can even imagine this is
in the game is as a response to the
growing genre of Pokemon creepypasta
online it kind of seems like something
that would happen in one of those
stories where the cartridge is hacked or
haunted and the game behaves in some
stranger creepy way maybe the developers
put this in to bait people into writing
their own stories and theories as sort
of a viral marketing campaign built into
the game if that's the case then I guess
it worked because Here I am talking
about it in front of you people right
now by the way I may do more videos on
creepy things in non horror media if
you're interested in seeing them so let
me know by answering this poll right
here I also haven't covered even half
the creepy things in Pokemon so if you
want me to do a part two leave a comment
and tell me to do a part two and if
you're new to the channel I'm known as
Suzy I make horror films and I do these
narrations so here's the deal I'll make
with you if you're interested in seeing
creepy stuff like you just saw I can get
you more of that all you have to do is
two things first
subscribe to seize these world for new
Horrors every week second ring that
victreebel for notifications if you
don't ring the bell you won't be able to
see any of my videos that's just how
YouTube works now so if that all sounds
good to you then I will see you in the
next one assuming we both survive